سليم
بجهه حمام الانف في محافظات بن عروس
استقبلتنا السيده لطيفه حامله صوره ابنها
بين يديها وتخنقها العبرات في حديثها عنه
هي واحده من الاف الامهات التي اكتوينا
بنار الهجره غير النظاميه
حكايتها تعود الى 12 سنه خلف عندما ركب
ابنها صبري احد قوارب الموت رغم تحصيله
شهاده جامعيه ومنذ ذلك الحين وهي تنتظر
عودته
حاسي بودي ولولا اللي معه الى متى
بين ضيفتي المتوسطي احلام جولي التونسيين
الباحثين عن مستقبل افضل احلام
الموت والهجره غير النظاميه جثث الالاف من
اصحابها في واحده من اقصى قصص المعاناه
الانسانيه التي قد لا تكفي المعالجه
الامنيه لايجاد حل لها قصه صبري الاف
المهاجرين غير النظاميين تؤرق السلطات
التونسيه ونظيرتها الايطاليه وزير
الخارجيه والداخليه الايطاليين يحلان
بتونس وعلى طويله النقاش مع المسؤولين
التونسيين هذا الملف شاك اما ما رشح فهو
ضروره اعتماد مقاربه شامله لهذه الظاهره
تتجاوز البعد الامنيه
للهجره اكدنا مجددا انه يجب معالجته هذه
الظاهره من جذورها المشكله ليست امنيه فقط
رغم انها كذلك يجب فهم الاسباب التي تدفع
الالاف والالاف لمغادره بلدانهم نحو الضفه
الشماليه من المتوسط ورغم هذه التاكيدات
الرسميه تتهم منظمات المجتمع المدني
المعنيه بملف الهجره تتهم سلطات التونسيه
ونظراتها الاوروبيه بعدم البحث عن اسبابها
العميقه
وتوفير الاطر والاليات المناسبه لمعالجه
الظاهره
من السلطه خاصه الايطاليه انها تدفع في
اموال ليست
سبعه قوارب للحراسه وانما مشيع له الشباب
وبلغه الارقام وصلت 18000 تونسيه السنه
الماضيه الى السواحل الايطاليه فيما بلغ
عدد الواصلين خلال نصف الاول من يناير
الحاليه اكثر من الف و 1700 شخص وليد عبد
الله العربيه تونس